I have all the puppies trying to form a
thought well there's puppies
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so our records since take this to your
grave have gone color palette blue and
then red and blue in the red and I think
that when you first played young in
Venice for me I just felt like it was
maybe that song self especially purple
to me it felt like a left turn
[Music]
yeah no one's ever brought me a puppy
yet don't look got the questions you
want the answer son
I think it would be great it's just
really agreeing on the songs or creating
cool original songs we have one
Christmas ish type song holiday-ish
types on but it was recorded a long time
ago
this is a very focused interview
I have never talked to munot about it I
think he explained the picture and the
explaination like Kyle's a little bit of
the magic out of it possibly he's like
just like he was surprised to see a
pop-up photographer bumped him or
something yeah um you go down it's like
a slide
[Laughter]
[Music]
so yeah the new sound I don't know that
there is a new sound you know it's just
every song is going to be a different
thing and that's something the record is
not gonna sound like in a minute no and
I mean that's the thing is it's not a
style you know like that's I don't think
we've for a long time I don't think
we've been very easy to you know if we
wrote a song that sounded too
specifically like a style you know we we
don't really use it so tell me
everything
tell me all the tell me about the song
um whisper sweet nothings in my ear I
don't know I think I answered it I got
lost in puppy I think that it like when
something is like disruptive and
interesting and and counterintuitive
it's interesting but then when it
becomes the thing that's expected
yeah like harder to that's what it like
I don't know so I didn't want to be a
gimmick it was the thing that we did
naturally and then when it started to be
the thing that people commented on all
the time it's like well we got an answer
that anymore ah belly rubs belly rubs hi
we get it so many One Tree Hill
questions it's it's really funny because
like because that was like maybe what
you did it for a minute but but in
general it was a very you know it was
like maybe a few days out of our entire
life you know so like it's funny how
often I get asked about that alright I
mean it was awesome it was really fun
but
[Applause]
I've answered this one before I think
but I mean but not with puppies that's
true but now there's like I would do it
if we can attach the right director you
know we're if we can do this project
move you know really that's all tied up
with the aliens disfranchise aliens
stuff you know it originally it was
looking good but I mean I'm gonna be
like really Groot imma be gravely honest
not in front of the puppies peer it it's
it's interesting to try and be like when
you're in a band for life in a band for
Michael over 15 years and in some places
we've played the city 20-plus times and
you're playing in an arena where there's
like some hardcore fans and there's like
hardcore fans from from ten years ago
and you know like and so it's like quite
a task to try and do put a setlist
together that's going to please
everybody but at the same time I think
that the thing that we've all said that
we wanted to do more and be better about
is like kind of rotating songs a little
bit good answer I thought about a shake
look at that look at that do it again
buddy you can do it
[Music]
probably not it was expensive and this
is one of those things that's super
funny that no one knew about is we have
wire work in that video all of it got
cut but it costs like a house it was so
crazy I can't believe we wasted money on
it and like and it didn't even work it
looked really stupid it's one of those
things my robe made it well like yeah
there are some things that like it's
more funny - or more interesting again -
probably like think about what it would
be like but if we actually did that
video people would prob be great
probably yeah the sequel video to that I
don't know if that would work so hard
playing for President Obama's inaugural
ball with people crazy that was that was
a thing like you know he'll tell
grandkids about that that's pretty wild
I thought you were first second were
saying that Obama will tell his
grandkids you know you'll never believe
that one time when they were great
so the first record take this your grave
was really fun and really awesome I'm
really proud of it but that was us like
we were still learning how to be a band
and we weren't really very ambitious
about it I mean like I think you know
all of us were like yeah we'll do this
for this would be a really awesome thing
to do well we're on you know a semester
off from school and then and then dance
dance was the first song to me where we
kind of were our own band we weren't
really trying to be anybody else we were
kind of you know when people ask me
every record every song we put out
there's always the you know what's with
the new sound you know and that's been
for like you know 12 years of follow-up
records that people been asking that and
I think the start of that is dance dance
I would love to break down the thing of
like of like fans being special right
like that was a thing that week that's
where we came from you know when we were
playing in hardcore bands and like in
these and he's like you know dumpy dive
bars and things like that like there
really wasn't any separation between
audience and band except for that the
van had guitars and whatever and then
something happened where like it became
this thing of like you sign autographs
and you take pictures and stuff which is
awesome and I'm happy to do that but it
was it it was a weird thing it's always
been a weird thing to me that that
that's a thing that separates you you're
not you're not part of the audience
anymore now I like that I miss that
in the early 2000s were one big fashion
regret for me it's one thing to like hat
like everyone does crazy fashion stuff
but to do it unlike the cover of Rolling
Stone it yeah Wow
it's really hard to focus when there's
like baby animals around I feel like we
kind of answered a couple questions but
like didn't really answer them yeah
these guys are all adoptable and you can
adopt them at North Shore Animal League
America and you own all hahaha
congratulations hope that hotels puppy
friendly
Oh